the earthquake struck in the early hours
of Tuesday collapsing homes cutting
power and causing landslides along the
southern coast of the island officials
from the United States Geological Survey
say around 400,000 people felt strong
too very strong shaking the tsunami
alert was cancelled as residents
scrambled to escape their homes
I was sleeping when the house began
falling bit by bit I grabbed my bag van
outside and jumped off the balcony man
it was terrible I don't wish that on
anybody several powerful aftershocks
followed as emergency services say
communicating with the affected
communities remains a challenge in guire
near the historic Immaculate Conception
Church built in 1841 suffered extensive
damage a rock formation known as window
Point a major tourist attraction now
lays in ruins the initial earthquake an
intense aftershocks were felt in the
islands capital San Juan to the
northeast of the epicentre aftershocks
are expected to continue in the coming
days officials say power should be
restored in the next few hours that the
island has been rattled by hundreds of
small quakes since the end of December
the islands fragile infrastructure
battered by Hurricane Marija two years
ago may hamper recovery efforts and
people here remain fearful nobody made
me react self-weight I got really okay
my first reaction was to run and find my
sister's my niece my mother my father
they were the ones that I was most
worried about and it was strong an
unforgettable day in the past few years
Puerto Rico has been hit by hurricanes
economic woes in a political crisis that
saw the islands governor are stood from
office many residents are now dealing
with yet another catastrophe the full
extent of which may not be known for
days and a Galica al Jazeera